[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
mitri sirin schönen guten abend wir
haben das wichtigste an diesem sonntag
für sie und sportliches gehört dazu
heute mit norbert kühn ja und dann
schauen wir jetzt gemeinsam auf die
themen im überblick
für ein schärferes kartellrecht
wirtschaftsminister habeck will härter
gegen ölkonzerne vorgehen weil sie den
tank rabatt nicht vollständig
weitergeben
parlamentswahl in frankreich präsident
makro muss um die absolute mehrheit
seines bündnisses in der
nationalversammlung angeln
und erfolg für red bull weltmeister max
verstappen gewinnt den großen preis von
aserbaidschan
ja das ging fix beim momentanen aufreger
thema nummer eins dem umstrittenen tank
rabatt steigt offenbar die politische
nervosität nach kritik aus der
oppositionellen cdu gestern an
wirtschaftsminister habe endlich zu
handeln legt dieser jetzt pläne vor um
das kartellrecht etwa für
mineralölkonzerne zu verschärfen im
notfall sollen sogar unternehmens
zerschlagung möglich sein mehr von jan
fritsche die kritik war zuletzt lauter
geworden wirtschaftsminister habeck
müsse härter gegen die mineralölkonzerne
vorgehen heute reagiert der minister das
war es als entlastung für die
bürgerinnen und bürger die verbrauchern
die verbraucher gedacht war geht in die
taschen der großen mineralölkonzerne
dass man darüber sauer ist empört das
was nicht richtig sein kann ist völlig
klar deswegen will habe ich jetzt das
kartellrecht verschärfen auch ohne
direkten nachweis illegaler
preisabsprachen sollen die
wettbewerbshüter harte maßnahmen
ergreifen können etwa profite der
konzerne einziehen oder sie notfalls
sogar zerschlagen der adac lobt die
initiative habe es statt der
versprochenen 35 cent preisnachlass für
benzin und 17 cent für diese komme viel
weniger bei den autofahrern an beim
benzin sind es etwa 20 cent im vergleich
zum vor der steuersenkung und bei diesel
ist es noch weniger sind es nur 5 cent
also voll umfänglich kommt der rabatt
nicht beim verbraucher an ursprünglich
war der tank rabatt eine idee der fdp
von selbstkritik bei deren chef heute
abend aber keine spur stattdessen
zustimmung zu habe es pläne und die
erneute absage an eine steuer auf
übermäßige gewinnen ich hoffe dass der
vorschlag dieser sogenannten über gewinn
steuer damit vom tisch ist denn die
würde unser steuerrecht der willkür und
den politischen stimmungsschwankungen
ausliefern die mineralölkonzerne selbst
bestreiten habe es vorwürfe und
verweisen auf gestiegene
beschaffungskosten kritik an den plänen
des ministers auch von der opposition
auch wenn kein missbrauch
begangen worden ist dass dann das
kartellamt eingreifen darf das wetter
rechtlich so gar nicht möglich sein für
kurzfristige entlastungen an der
zapfsäule dürften habe es pläne ohnehin
nicht sorgen er hofft auf eine umsetzung
noch dieses jahr und so dürfte der
streit um den tank rabatt weitergehen
mehr zum thema sie habe gerade gesehen
mit finanzminister lindner in berlin
direkt nach unserer sendung gerade jetzt
in einer zeit in der das verständnis für
andere lebensentwürfe und meinungen
abnimmt kann eine soziale pflicht
besonders wertvoll sein sagte
bundespräsident steinmeier der bild am
sonntag und forderte damit einen
pflichtdienst für alle jungen menschen
familienministerin poß hält nicht allzu
viel davon und argumentiert mit der
individuellen freiheit eines jeden
jugendlichen außerdem hätten sie in der
korona zeit besonders gelitten
wenn frankreichs präsident makro neue
gesetze verabschieden wollte konnte er
sich bislang immer auf eine bequeme
mehrheit verlassen und das könnte sich
vielleicht nach den parlamentswahlen
ändern heute die erste runde laut
jüngsten umfragen zeichnet sich ein kopf
an kopf rennen mit dem links grünen
bündnis mit jean-luc mélenchon ab dieser
hatte sich mit den sozialisten den
grünen und den kommunisten zusammen
getan und sich als neuer premier ins
gespräch
wir gehen nach paris zu thomas walde
thomas wonach sich jetzt aus
zunächst einmal nach einer historisch
niedrigen beteiligung der aktuellen
hochrechnung wird am ende dieses ersten
wahlgang ist nicht einmal die hälfte
aller berechtigten an die urne gegangen
sein vor allem viele jüngere bleiben zu
hause während ältere überproportional an
die urnen gehen letzteres könnte markus
lager zu gute kommen heute geht es ja
darum wie viel macht marco in den
kommenden fünf jahren haben wird wie
viele seiner reformen eher durch das
parlament bringen kann etwa die reform
das renteneintrittsalter zu erhöhen von
62 auf 65 jahre das und vieles andere
will das neue links bündnis verhindern
dass sich eigens vor dieser wahl
gebildet hat und das französische
mehrheitswahlrecht belohnt die die sich
vor einem wahlgang zusammentun darum
wird ein kopf-an-kopf-rennen zwischen
makros lager und dem linksbündnis
erwartet in vielen wahlkreisen denn 577
wahlkreisen die es gibt wird heute
niemand wahrscheinlich die absolute
mehrheit erreichen und darum wird es
dort stichwahlen geben das heißt das
genaue ergebnis und wie viel macht makro
haben wird wissen wir dann am kommenden
sonntag um 20 uhr es bleibt spannend in
frankreich dank an paris thomas walde
nach langer zurückhaltung will
bundeskanzler scholz angeblich doch in
die ukraine reisen noch diesen monat mit
dabei seien frankreichs präsident makro
und italiens regierungschef draghi so
bild am sonntag in der ost ukraine
halten die kämpfe an etwa in lizenz
prorussischen kräfte attackieren
offenbar auch zivile ziele im westen des
landes gab es russische raketen angriffe
auf eine militäreinrichtung und nahe
person im süden drängten ukrainische
streitkräfte russische einheiten zurück
so angaben aus kiew
täglich berichten wir über das
dramatische kriegsgeschehen in der
ukraine über und in russland zu
berichten aus journalistischer
perspektive ist wie sie wissen schwierig
wir das wort krieg verwendet der läuft
gefahr bestraft zu werden in diesem
spannungsverhältnis ist der bericht von
axel sturm entstanden der für uns in
moskau ist
die menge am puschkinplatz in moskau hat
eindeutig hunger aber sie muss warten
denn vor den warmen bürgern gibt es
warme worte
wir sind sehr froh dass ihr heute hier
seid ein event das strahlkraft haben
soll frittieren und braten kann russland
auch das soll die nachricht sein und
damit diese auch verbreitet wird stehen
fast mehr journalisten in der filiale
als kunden die kette nennt sich übrigens
jetzt lecker und punkt ist es wie früher
ich finde es etwas zu salzig
850 filialen will der geschäftsmann
sofort wieder eröffnen es soll
weitergehen nur eben anders kein zweifel
so scheint es soll aufkommen am zustand
der wirtschaft dabei beginnen die
sanktionen zu greifen zwar sind die
regale in den supermärkten noch gut
gefüllt aber die preise stark gestiegen
bei einer rente von 20.000 rubeln etwa
330 euro merkt man das alles ist rund 30
prozent teurer geworden
früher hat der laib brot 36 ruhige
kostet heute 64 rubel
teures leben unsichere zukunft mit der
haben sowohl befürworter als auch gegner
der sogenannten
spezialoperation zu kämpfen auch
anastasia eine zahnmedizinstudenten
wir merken die sanktionen im
medizinischen bereich stark uns gehen
einige materialien aus ich spüre dass
täglich im job es fehlt an instrumenten
und an arbeitsmaterial
wie es wohl weitergeht wie ihr leben für
den tag sagen uns viele menschen das
morgen stehe in den sternen
in berlin haben sich heute zehntausende
radler verabredet um in die pedale zu
treten mit einer sternfahrt mitten durch
die hauptstadt strampelten sie für
bessere bedingungen für fahrradfahrer
und dafür waren viele straßen gesperrt
und sogar die stadtautobahn
wir machen jetzt mit dem sport weiter
und norbert könig und ich sag nur eins
zu eins viel vorgenommen wenig
abgeliefert wieder mal drei mal eins zu
eins die letzten arbeitstage vor dem
höchst verdienten sommerurlaub stellt
man sich anders vor die dfb-elf bleibt
auch im dritten gruppenspiel der nations
league ohne sieg aber eben auch ohne
niederlage nach dem 1 1 in budapest
das comeback in die weltspitze stopp
deutschland hängt dem unentschieden
modus drei punkte aus drei spielen ist
nicht den anspruch den wir den laden und
stellen wenn man es mir vorgenommen wir
konnten uns zu unserem warten
erwartungen eigentlich dafür die
selbstkritik fehlt nicht beim
rückschritt gegen umgang
so ein bisschen die leichtigkeit hat
einfach heute gefehlt hier in budapest
der einzige weltklassespieler manuel
neuer der älteste mit 36 ist meistens so
wenn torwart um
herausragend ist und dann stimmt ein
bisschen was im spiel nicht trotz des
ausgleichs von jonas hofmann die flaute
im sturm bleibt deutschland sucht einen
mittelstürmer
[Applaus]
der titelverteidiger ist auf kurs in der
formel 1 max verstappen gewinnt in
baku/aserbaidschan den achten wm lauf
dieser saison
weltmeister max verstappen holt im red
bull den fünften saisonsieg den 25 in
seiner karriere sein teamkollege sergio
perez gewinnt den start gegen polesetter
schale claire und geht in führung
geschickte boxenstrategie bringt le
claire wieder an die spitze doch in der
zwanzigsten runde fällt der ferrari
pilot mit motorschaden aus sebastian
vettel fährt sein bestes rennen in der
saison und wird am ende sechster ich
glaube ich überwiegt das positive mit
den punkten mehr als wir glaube ich
zusammen bisher also ja war das war für
uns richtig doppelerfolg für fast ab und
perez dritter george russell im mercedes
der countdown läuft für die final berlin
wird in der übernächsten woche wieder
schauplatz für deutsche meisterschaften
in 14 sportarten auch topstars aus der
leichtathletik und im schwimmen sind am
start
190 titel werden vergeben ein
verlängertes sportwochenende ard und zdf
werden die finales in der hauptstadt
begleiten mit mehr als 25 stunden
programm kann man sich kaum noch was
anderes vornehmen vielen dank norbert
wir haben zum schluss noch die
wetteraussichten und die gehen so im
norden und osten wechselnd bewölkt mit
schauern und gewittern auch am alpenrand
anfangs noch gewittrige schauer sonst
freundlich mit viel sonne bei lebhaftem
nordwestwind 16 bis 25 grad und in den
nächsten tagen wird noch schöner das
heute journal um 21.45 mit marietta
slomka morgen ist hier viana pareigis
danke fürs zuschauen